a banquet cooked by michelin-starred
chef fine wine ornate outfits and plenty
of civilized conversation you notice
people that are willing to spend
hard-earned cash on the only and amazing
festival experience with amazing music
and facilities but also some top-notch
threw up as well
wilderness isn't like other music
festivals it's been dubbed posh stock
for the celebrity crowds it rolls this
year Prince Harry and even Bank of
England governor Mark Carney whole idea
is that everyone participates together
so it can be someone famous with someone
you know a lawyer mixed with you know a
and art student wilderness is tapping an
ever-growing crowd of festival goers who
favor posh over mosh pits and they're
willing to pay for the experience with
tickets up to 160 pounds a massage fifty
pounds and if you want a seat at the
chef's table 100 pounds the festival
attracted 30,000 people this summer
that's about twice as much as last year
well in the secret garden party a lot of
the audience wanting to just want to
move on from there kind of head nism and
get much more into kinda more healthy
living and learning actually how to live
this is a lucrative business but it's
not without its hazards today for
example this morning the weather was
beautiful now it's kind of warm but not
so beautiful you just kind of it's gonna
rain at some point you know it's gonna
rain it's as part of going to festivals
in England Caroline Hyde Bloomberg